[Musique]
la cour suprême de terrain
sur une période de cinq ans j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps
voyez moi ce n'était pas une partie de
plaisir
ineum à témoigner devant la cour suprême
de terre-neuve à plusieurs reprises son
plus long témoignage a duré cinq jours
il a raconté à la cour ce qu'il a vécu à
l'heure féline allemand cachot dans les
années 70 ce livre est aux mains d'une
bande de pervers qui appartenait au
christ une braderie ouverte
les frères chrétiens d'irlande mancka
jaune et le ground zero des pédophiles
de l'église au pays des mines avait à
peine de huit ans quand son père l'a
déposé lui son petit frère chaîne à
l'orphelinat
les parents avaient sept enfants et un
divorce sur les bras trois des garçons
au déterrement donné aux mains des
frères chrétiens
billy a été battues et agressées
sexuellement
quarante ans plus tard ce qu'il a vu le
réveil encore la nuit il entend les cris
de ses camarades de l'orphelinat qui se
font battre ou agressées sexuellement
l'abonnement pour décrire ce qu'on a
fait
ça fait quelques années que je suis
traité pour le stress post traumatique
[Musique]
paraît pas facilement
mais
au moins je suis là
[Musique]
moi
l'ampleur des agressions sexuelles à
mende cassol était inimaginable
des plus jeunes aux plus vieux et les
plus âgés qui deviennent à leur tour des
agresseurs c'est incroyable au milieu
des années 70 billy et quelques autres
dénoncent ce qui se passe à l'orphelinat
ça prend vraiment beaucoup de courage à
ces enfants qui ne sont même pas des
adolescents
les policiers ouvrent une enquête sera
votée lieux qui en est responsable
des témoignages et des aveux sont
recueillies mais le gouvernement ne veut
pas entendre parler de ce que vivent les
enfants manquent à chaud et exige que le
rapport des policiers ne parle surtout
pas d agression sexuelle grave des lieux
et forcé d'avoir del'enquête je ne
pardonnerai jamais à l'abri thonier le
responsable de la tête s'il avait eu
juste un peu de courage
un peu de coeur s'il s'était mis à notre
place il n'aurait jamais laissé tout ça
se produire
les religieux s'en sortent en toute
impunité et puis quinze ans plus tard en
1989 à la radio un journaliste eux
raconte ce qu'il sait des horreurs de
l'orphelinat par hasard parmi ceux qui
écoutent l'émission de radio il y a le
sou aux coureurs général adjoint de
terre-neuve il lui il va en avoir le
coeur net
l'enquêté policière est rouverte cette
fois des religieux et des laïcs sont
arrêtés et condamnés
une commission royale d'enquêté mise sur
pied et pendant des jours des semaines
des mois c'est tout pays qui entend avec
stupeur ce que ces criminels en soutane
font subir à billy et ses enfants sans
ressources
c'était énorme toute la communauté était
en état de choc
à l'époque jean louis fut n'était de
jeunes journalistes et rien ne l'avait
préparé à ce qu'il allait entendre
pendant les travaux de la commission
denquête aed ces procès d'amon faire
passer pas mal de nuits blanches
je n'arrivais pas à croire ce que
j'entendais les gens étaient choqués
d'entendre les détails et l'ampleur de
ce qui s'était passé les gens
n'arrivaient pas à croire que ceux qui
devaient prendre soin de ses enfants
vulnérables leur faisait subir toute
cette violence
ces agressions sexuelles
[Musique]
c'étaient des enfants déjà abîmés par la
vie et sont tombés littéralement en
enfer avec silence
c'est comme ça que je les appelle des
monstres absolue
j'étais dégoûté quand j'ai compris ce
qui se passait dans certains médias même
le journal où je travaillais à l'époque
de nouvelles a reçu l'ordre de ne pas
enquêter sur ces histoires
ça m'a vraiment dégoûté comme
journaliste mais ça ça ne pourrait plus
produire aujourd'hui très manga shu est
une onde de choc terrible
mais quelques années plus tard l'autre
beau gosse ton
merci à tous ceux qui par leur faute ils
appellent 6% pour demander les 6% ça
fait 90 90 prêtre cissé salle où étaient
si nombreux les gens seraient peut-être
qu'il de salles le film spotlight
raconte coma en 2002 les journaliste du
boston globe découvre comment le diocèse
de post on a protégé des dizaines de
prêtres qui agressaient des enfants en
les déplaçant d'une paroisse à l'autre
avec la bénédiction du cardinal bernard
law qui déménage au vatican où il ne
sera plus jamais embêté depuis australie
belgique irlande canada en fait partout
en comprend que c'est le même stratagème
qui s'applique
c'est tellement énorme on se demande si
des films hollywoodiens comme spotlight
peut vraiment faire comprendre l'ampleur
de la super choses et pas seulement à
bostens c'est dans tout le pays dans le
monde entier
ils savaient et n'ont rien fait
ça aurait pu être toi t'aurais pu être
moi ç'aurait pu être n'importe qui
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à m'impliquer de 1984
parmi les sources des journalistes pas
son blog il y à un homme de l'intérieur
qui connaît très bien les rouages et
l'église catholique temps de noël
l'ancien prêtre tom doyle témoigner de
cet expert dans ses salles d'eau si
depuis le milieu des années 80 il a
participé à une foule denquête dans le
monde sur le sujet ce sont ces histoires
scabreuses qui lui ont fait perdre la
foi en institution je n'arrivais plus à
accepter qu'un système que des évêques
pardonne mêmes favorise des hommes qui
agressent des enfants et de très jeunes
adolescents
ben c'est un des pires crimes qu'ils
soient l'église dit aux gens comment
vivre leur sexualité et en même temps
elle laisse de telle chose se produire
je ne pouvais plus vivre avec une telle
hypocrisie
[Musique]
sur cette photo
ce sont les garçons en juin 1974 les
sites de bochum alors qu'on met la table
mais qu'on s'apprête à dire la prière on
peut voir craig lee décédé depuis
[Musique]
c'est moi il est mort il ya quelques
années
et ça c'est vrai qu'un message
il est décédé récemment
[Musique]
c'était une maison des horreurs
c'était une banque de dysfonctionnelle
de malades de tordus qui se servaient
des vieux garçons comme des objets
sexuels ou des punching bag et dans les
gares sont arrivés à se sauver
les policiers qui respecte m en cash au
les ramenait à l'orphelinat où il était
puni et violée à nouveau c'est toute une
culture à l'intérieur de l'orphelinat
que la société pour digérer mais c'est
quoi la différence entre eux et de crise
il n'y en a pas
peu importe qui comme le crime viol et
des enfants ces deux crimes
un point c'est tout
des fonctionnaires les politiciens
la police
les services sociaux un quart dinan
doss et en europe
terra world auraient ils s'en sont tous
tirés
da soit dans nos stades
rodrigo je n'arrive pas à comprendre ces
gens-là sens sauf sans jamais être
accusés sans aucune conséquence
je comprends vraiment pas
[Musique]
pour des milliers de survivants de
prêtres pédophiles dans le monde
l'élection du pape françois a soulevé un
réel espoir à dublin en irlande
marie kohl's ya vraiment cru
[Musique]
voir mon père aimait la photographie et
il a fait ce portrait de moi
[Musique]
malheureusement mon agresseur aussi
s'intéresser aux photos et il en a pris
pendant qu'il m'agressait à l'hôpital il
a pris beaucoup de photos indécentes
il m'a aussi envoyé cette photo si
lorsque je suis sorti de l'hôpital ce
qui m'a causé beaucoup de stress marie
n'avait que 13 ans lorsqu'elle a dû être
hospitalisé one chez elle l'hôpital qui
devait être un lieu de guérison était en
fête le territoire d'un prédateur elle
nous monnier catholiques d' assassin's
lui père paul mcguinness la photo a été
prise lorsqu'il a été déclaré coupable
il m'a dit qu'il ne pouvait faire de mal
puisqu'il était prêtre et que j'avais un
sérieux problème si je pensais que ce
qu'il me faisait très mal
il avait du pouvoir il était respecté
il était tellement manipulateur et tous
ce ne sont que trois semaines de ma vie
que j'ai passées à l'hôpital pendant
lesquelles j'étais à sa merci mais après
j'avais tellement honte
j'avais l'impression d'être une si
mauvaise personne comme si tout était de
ma faute
myphone après vingt ans de profonde
dépression mari raconte son histoire un
prêtre qui la reçoit comme trop souvent
les victimes de prêtres pédophiles ont
été dans l'église catholique
j'ai tout raconté à un prêtre de mon
quartier
sa réaction a été parfaitement
inapproprié il m'a dit que c'était de ma
faute mais qu'il me pardonnait mari ne
la prendrai que bien plus tard mais aux
tirs 16 on savait très bien que le money
était d'un criminel et malgré tout on
refusait de remettre son dossier aux
policiers
en irlande le drame de marie s'inscrit
dans un des pires scandales qui implique
des centaines de religieux et au delà de
14500 victimes c'est ce qu'ont démontré
plusieurs ancres une honte absolue pour
l'église catholique qui ne peut plus
prétendre à des cas isolés
[Musique]
lorsque françois est élu il met sur pied
une commission pour lutter contre les
agressions
parmi les membres de la commission aient
choisi nul autre que ma récolte
ce sont tous des documents de la
commission pontificale pour marie il y a
de quoi être fier c'est une occasion
historique de faire entendre la voix des
survivants de l'intérieur dans les plus
hautes sphères de l'église catholique
mais marine ne pouvait pas se douter de
ce qu'ils allaient découvrir au vatican
on a découvert qu'au vatican la
congrégation pour la doctrine de la foi
qui est responsable de tous les dossiers
d'agressions ne répond jamais lorsqu un
survivant un proche ou un thérapeute
écrit à la congrégation pour savoir si
son dossier a été réglé ou si son
agresseur a été défroqué on ne répond
jamais jamais
même pas un accusé de réception l'église
y que ce que ressentent les victimes
c'est important mais en même temps elle
ne leur réponds pas c'est comme si
l'église rejeter les victimes une fois
de plus est ce qui laisse perplexe
certains membres de la commission papale
c'est que malgré des invitations
répétées le pape françois ne se joindra
pâle pour travailler à ce qui était
apparemment la priorité de l'église
les actrices commisssion si le pape
était venue s'asseoir avec nous on
aurait pu lui parler de la détresse que
certains de ces commentaires ont osé ça
c'est un adulte un politicien je crois
qu'il devait entendre ces critiques
pyrrhus en deux et l'autre victime qui a
travaillé avec la première commission du
pape françois nous l'avons rencontrée en
2016 avant il avait prédit le chaos dans
lequel l'église et le pape françois les
se retrouver piteux et sorties de
l'expérience particulièrement déçu je me
suis souvent demandé dans quelle mesure
le pape était vraiment au courant de ce
qui se passait
s'est il par exemple à quel point des
survivants dans son propre pays sont
contrariés parce qu'il ne s'est pas
occupé d'eux
[Musique]
il n'y avait aucune collaboration entre
les différents départements du vatican
et nous ils refusaient de nous parler du
match au 8e d'un succès dès le départ
ils ont tout fait pour qu'on échoue
parce qu'ils nous percevait comme une
menace à leur autorité
[Musique]
il s'affiche à littéralement de la
sécurité des enfants ce qui était notre
préoccupation à nous ils s'en fichaient
saut amélie je ne veux pas être cynique
mais les fonctionnaires ont un énorme
contrôle sur le vatican ils ont eu des
siècles pour apprendre à tout contrôle
et des pâtisseries ce tour
[Musique]
nicolas sehnaoui correspondant pour le
quotidien la croix au vatican
et il connaît très bien le phénomène de
la résistance de la curie romaine
parce qu'il ya vraiment une presque une
guerre interne en tout elle une
résistance très forte qui se fait jour
et de plus en plus fortement de plus en
plus ouvertement contre les réformes
qu'elle en scène par françois soucy une
réforme qu'avant de l'église pour
répondre à la crise des abus sexuels et
donc revoir la façon dont le pouvoir
finalement son se distribuent dans
l'église catholique et ça forcément ça
gêne à beaucoup de monde dans les lieux
où il ya un nombre de personnes qui
refusent de voir que
le sifflet pour une intérieure nicolas
parle des réformes difficiles du père
françois voici l'exemple par excellence
dans l'église catholique
ce sont les évêques qui sont
responsables de la conduite du clergé
mais la commission papale ne croient
plus que des évêques tout ce réseau de
la crise la pédophile au contraire la
commission recommande à françois de
créer un nouveau tribunal pour juger les
évêques des archevêques et s'il le faut
les cardinaux qui ont couvert les
criminels le pape est d'accord et puis
plus rien ou est ce tribunal c'est ce
que j'ai demandé au président de la
commission ou et le tribunal il a levé
les mains en l'air et m'a dit je ne sais
pas peter
j'ai dit au pape que nous avions besoin
de règles universelles pour protéger les
enfants partout sur la planète et il m'a
répondu oh nous ne pouvons pas imposer
les mêmes règles à tous les évêques
il m'a vraiment dit ça qu'on ne peut pas
imposer les mêmes règles à tous les
évêques il faut tenir compte de leur
culture et de leur compréhension du
problème et je lui ai répondu non à nice
et nos idées
après trois ans de travail et de
frustration avec le sentiment que
reviennent à l'avancé marie collin scac
la porte de la commission s'il avait
autant à coeur la souffrance des
victimes de leur volonté d'éviter le
scandale alors nous n'aurions pas cette
crise il s'occuperait de la situation
correctement mais ils ne le font pas ils
croient que leur cléricalisme leurs
traditions interne leur manière de faire
sont bien plus importants que la
protection des gens ordinaires qui ont
été blessées dans l'église puis 202 on
lui a demandé de ne plus présenter aux
réunions de la commission
personne sur terre ne peut vraiment
comprendre la complexité et le pouvoir
de la curie ils peuvent faire
obstruction à n'importe quoi et ils le
font c'est ce qui est arrivé à marie
collin dit peter sands qui ont
démissionné de la commission
précisément parce que les fonctionnaires
du vatican leur barrer la route à la
commission n'aboutissent à rien et
personne n'était là pour contrecarrer la
curie
[Musique]
depuis la démission de marie qods le
pape a mis sur pied une nouvelle équipe
une nouvelle commission
seul le temps dira si elle aura
davantage d'impact sur la tempête qui
frappe l'église
[Musique]
trente ans après que n'éclate au grand
jour les horaires de malgaches aux
délits essaie de mener une vie aussi
normale que possible je peux y venait
lui qui a longuement témoigné devant un
tribunal
le voici aujourd'hui huissier de justice
il livre des documents pour la coupe
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est un événement cachot refuse de
s'effacer de sa mémoire
comment expliquer que tant d'années plus
tard tous en short les terrains sont
moins impressionnants what was comme
quoi s'il ya une question qu'on se pose
c'est chris braden ue
c'est quoi la différence entre les
frères chrétiens d'irlande que vous avez
connu une bande de criminels
il n'y pas de différences et nos défauts
il y en a pas les criminels agissent de
la même manière comme choisi dit je peux
compter sur les doigts d'une main ce qui
était bon et puis il y avait des
professeurs qui savait ce qui se passait
j'avais des travailleurs sociaux
ils ont bien fait
[Musique]
plusieurs des frères chrétiens que billy
a connu à l'orphelinat manque à chaud
ont été envoyés en prison
démont crois pas une seconde pendant
qu'ils soient les uniques responsables
du drame et il n'est pas le seul à se
poser la question
encore aujourd'hui il y a des victimes
présumées des années 45 ans qui voudrait
bien que l'élise et peut être même le
vatican soient tenus responsables de ce
qu'ils ont vécu un manque à chaud
[Musique]
tenir le vatican responsable de ce qui
s'est passé relève effectivement c'est
tout un défi
le vatican c'est un monde à part il y à
3 mais l'évêque axée sur la planète
c'est une confrérie solidaire des mains
et des gens qui savent se protéger entre
eux anthony figueiredo on en sait
quelque chose
son histoire est singulière il est
maintenant connue dans les plus hautes
sphères du vatican monseigneur
figueiredo comme il aime bien se faire
rappeler avec son titre honorifique a
osé parler publiquement
[Musique]
si quelqu'un était moins d'abus graves
il doit sonner l'alertent et dire assez
c'est assez
enough is enough on arrête ça parce que
jusqu'ici c'était un jeu pour être
honnête je crois que plusieurs évêques
certainement en amérique se percevait et
se perçoivent encore comme des pdg de
grandes entreprises
pas si étonnant coopération ils sont
alors comme des roues dans leur château
en ecosse compris ils n'ont de compte à
rendre à personne
[Musique]
personne n'a vu arriver anthony
figueiredo il a été le secrétaire du
cardinal mais carrick et plus tard
lorsqu'il est déménagée à rome il a
servi d'intermédiaire entre le cardinal
et le saint siège
anthony figueiredo connais beaucoup de
choses embarrassantes sur le cardinal
qui est au coeur d'un grave scandale
theodore mccarrick était le gardien le
plus respecté des états unis archevêque
de washington il avait des liens directs
avec la papauté
selon le washington post tiré d'un conte
discrétionnaire auxquelles il avait
accès mais carrick aurait versé des
sommes surprenante à différents membres
du clergé dont près d'un demi million de
dollar à jean paul ii et à benoît 16
pourtant depuis très longtemps
des allégations circulaient à propos de
mes carrick le prestigieux cardinal
invité de jeunes séminaristes a partagé
son lit il aurait même agressé un mineur
selon une enquête du vatican qui a
néanmoins beaucoup tardé à sévir c'est
renversant surtout quand on sait qu'il
était perçu comme le porte parole des
évêques américains sur la question de la
pédophilie
figueiredo en sa possession une
correspondance qui tend à démontrer que
le cas mais carrick était certainement
connu de bonnes recettes et
vraisemblablement de françois mais alors
que devait faire figueiredo de ces
informations privilégiées
les divulguer ou se taire à cinq
reprises
j'ai écrit à mon évêque monseigneur
tobin à propos de cette correspondance
je suis allé voir deux cardinaux dont le
cardinal responsable du clergé à rome je
lui montrais la correspondance vitesse
je lui demandais ce que je devais en
faire
le cardinal m'a dit d'en parler avec mon
évêque mais il m'a dit que cette
correspondance n'était pas pertinente à
notre conversation
voilà qui a de quoi surprendre deux
cardinaux qui semble considérer sans
intérêt une correspondance qui démontre
que de très hauts placés dans l'église
était au courant des agressions mécary
depuis des années comment peut-on
expliquer manque d'intérêt pour des
informations aussi explosif
en vérité mon évêque voulait que je me
taise si j'étais rentré dans mon diocèse
aux états unis que me serait-il arrivé
il aurait eu le contrôle sur vous il
aurait eu un contrôle absolu sur moi et
qui sait peut-être qu'après il l'aurait
dit quelqu'un a porté plainte contre
vous vous comprenez ce que je veux dire
je serai mis hors d'état de nuire
je suis désolé de le dire mais ce sont
des choses qui arrivent
figueiredo finira par publié des
extraits de cette correspondance
embarrassante et il n'est pas seul à
sonner l'alarmé d'un autre personnage
controversé fait trembler les colonnes
du vatican monseigneur carlo maria
vigano
[Musique]
la corruption atteint le sommet de la
hiérarchie de l'église écrit monseigneur
vigano dans une lette vitriolic qu'il se
décide à publier le 26 ou 2018
dans cette lettre de 11 pages
monseigneur vigano l'ex ambassadeur du
saint siège à washington soutient avoir
averti françois en personne peu de temps
après son élection que le cardinal
mikari se trouvait au coeur d'un
scandale sexuel
il ne demande rien de moins que la
démission du pape françois
la lettre de vigano à l'effet d'une
bombe nucléaire au vatican et
aujourd'hui personne ne sait vraiment où
se trouve vigano parce que dit-on il
craint pour sa vie
grâce à un collaborateur nous sommes
entrés en contact avec vigano qui nous a
dit vouloir se battre pour l'église
manifestement envers et contre tous mais
pour le moment il préfère se tenir loin
des caméras
je peux vous dire que j'ai rencontré le
patron soit à plusieurs reprises la
première fois que je lui ai parlé du
cardinal mais carrick
honnêtement il m'a dit qu'il n'était pas
au courant
alors personne ne lui a dit moi comment
est ce possible que dans l'entourage du
père françois parmi ses conseillers
personne ne lui ai parlé du scandale
mais carrick qui atteint les plus hautes
sphères de l'élise ne pas françois
sauvette il à ce point isolé du monde
[Musique]
je peux vous dire qu'il ya actuellement
une enquête au vatican rond quand price
et pour la première fois
c'est vraiment une enquête plus poussée
finalement après des années de rumeurs
mais carrick personnes titre de cardinal
ce qui ne s'était pas vu depuis des
siècles et puis il est défroqué mais le
plus troublant c'est que mikari qui
n'est pas un cas unique dans les hautes
sphères du vatican ils y allaient
cardinal world le successeur de
washington qui ne se souvenait plus de
rien de la faire avant de présenter sa
démission au pape de s'excuser
publiquement et de disparaître sans être
embêté encore plus jeune entre la sphère
du cardinal pell le numéro trois du
vatican un homme de confiance du parc
françois qui aujourd'hui se retrouve
derrière les barreaux en australie pour
avoir agressé des enfants coeur ou
encore l'ex protégée du père françois
monseigneur juan barros accusé d'avoir
couvert des agressions sexuelles ou
chili et puis en france le cardinal
barbarin qui a été reconnu coupable au
criminel
et puis acquitté d'avoir suis de n'avoir
rien fait dans la sphère du père prélat
qui agressaient des centaines d'enfants
encore une fois des victimes diront que
les licences embiez facilement
ça fait quand même beaucoup d'hommes
dans les plus hautes instances de
l'église qui devaient être d'une
moralité irréprochable et qui se
retrouve plutôt au coeur de la plus
grave crise qu'a connue l'église
catholique dans les siècles derniers
[Musique]
lorsque j'ai travaillé à l'ambassade du
vatican à washington j'ai dû jurer de
garder le silence sur tout ce que j
apprendrai c'est ce qu'on appelle le
secret pontifical plus tard à plusieurs
reprises j'ai violé mon serment
on m'a dit tu a violé son serment et
j'ai dit oui
je n'ai pas prêté serment pour protéger
des agresseurs sexuels n'est pas prêté
serment pour permettre à des gens de
violer des enfants ni pour perpétuer la
malhonnêteté alors oui j'ai brisé mon
serment et c'était légitime
sur les côtes de terre-neuve bélie en
rage en voyant comment tous ces gens
s'en sortent toujours on peut pardonner
mais on n'oublie jamais les blessures et
les douleurs sont toujours à bord jamais
pourquoi la justice ne frappe jamais le
gouvernement
déjà vulnérables qui viennent de milieux
dysfonctionnelle des jeunes démunis les
utiliser comme des jouets sexuels de les
exploiter comme ça à retenter n'être que
des [ __ ]
tout récemment le père françois le vil
secret pontifical pour les cas
d'agressions sont des minables
pour le moment on n'a aucune idée des
effets de cette décision
par exemple tous les évêques qui
savaient qu'ils n'ont rien dit vont-ils
maintenant faire des aveux publics
[Musique]
on
au canada aucun évêque n'a été condamné
pour ne pas avoir dénoncé des pédophiles
dans l'église
aucun comme si les évêques ne veut pas
de compte à rendre à la société civile
au québec seulement nous avons recensé
près de 25 recours collectif dont
plusieurs sont en attente d'autorisation
contre des congrégations religieuses ou
encore contre des diocèses comme celui
de chicoutimi une photo à l'époque que
j'ai connus l'adar v pour les premières
fois je t'aime beaucoup plus jeune c'est
lui qui nous confirmait pts qui nous
communique inoa et que faisait bien
d'autres choses aussi
qu'est ce que vous voyez dans cette
photo là vous
[Musique]
je pense pas
babel sa nouvelle fait
oui
mais qu'est ce
à chicoutimi susan était tout jeune
lorsque l'abbé hervé a posé les mains
sur elle la première fois elle voulait
le crier sur tous les toits
mais à l'époque la vie des villes et des
villages du québec tourne est tellement
autour de l'église catholique
intouchable
et ainsi d j'étais battu j'ai été abusée
sexuellement j'ai été agressée
sexuellement
quand ils voyaient ce qui m'arrivait y
avait pas le goût de sa rivale deux
enfants c'est à la loi de l'omerta lors
ceux ci s'étaient carrément ensemble les
gens savaient mais personne n'osait
affronter un à la fin comme l'église
catholique
s'il ya quelqu'un qui savait ça c'est
bien celle que susan allait nous
présenter sa mère nous avons assisté un
moment plutôt exceptionnelle des années
après les agressions
la mère et la fille ont encore des
choses à apprendre quand elle a appris
que sa fille était agressé par un frère
un ami de la famille par surcroît
désemparés thérèse est allé demander
conseil au chef de police
non vous êtes allé voir le policier que
vous connaissez mais j'allais jersey
avec lui j'ai raconté cette histoire
l'espagne en tête à deux mains et du
pauvre tout fait il dit les autres ont
pu rien faire
les l'église ils ont leurs propres lois
je vais du monde qu'est ce que c'est que
j'en fais un bon affronterez monseigneur
je dis quoi aller raconte rue
monseigneur pareil jamais de la vie
en fait c'était tellement inimaginable
tout ça que même le père de susan
croyait que sa fille lui mottet qu'elle
cherchait à salir l'image de l'abbé
avait fauché il s'était levé puis avec
des manches et sa ceinture de culotte
puis le passé j'avais 9 ans je me
préparais pour lui faire sans citer que
je laisse sommet avec le point là pour
qu'allah ait failli le tuer ça aurait pu
arriver et imagine la ceinture ça je
m'en rappelle pierre je pleurais puis je
me rappelle mon assiette à me servais
mon assise dans mon assiette c'est être
inversée mais
je me souvenais pas à pas je découvre
des affaires
[Musique]
à chicoutimi entre 1963 et 1987 à lui
seul l'abbé paul andré harvey a agressé
39 victimes surtout de très jeunes
filles et de son propre aveu il y avait
probablement beaucoup plus de victimes
que ça l'abbé hervé a été condamné à la
prison où il est décédé en 2010 8 ans et
cruz 6 ans et qui les cachent et qui
parle à qui les cachent des laisse
continuer à donner libre cours à leurs
perversions ce soir susan a rendez vous
avec son avocat qui représente une
centaine de victimes présumées qui en
2016 ont entrepris un recours collectif
non seulement contre l'abbé hervé mais
aussi contre le diocèse de chicoutimi
son évêque neuf paroisses ainsi que les
assureurs du diocèse et s'il le faut
contre le vatican
le regroupement des victimes alléguées
réclame 14 millions de dollars pour
négligence
rien n'a encore été prouvé devant les
tribunaux le diocèse et ses assureurs se
renvoient la balle mais pour m johnston
il n'y a pas que l'agresseur qui est
coupable c'est criminel de perm est un
criminel de commettre un crime et y est
ce qu'on a c'est une institution complet
qui fascinait
et qui permet à des pédophiles d'avoir
accès à de nouvelles victimes c'est
exactement le corps pour l'abbé hervé
guerrera a réussi si un prêtre pédophile
il faut bien comprendre que la
différence entre un prêtre pédophile qui
fait deux ou trois victimes puis
qu'ensuite s'ils avaient été confrontés
par l'institution de l'église les
victimes sans s'arrêter ça mais au lieu
de ça c'est sans victimes et les 97
victimes qui étaient pour cette première
c'est la responsabilité de l'église et
est en réalité pas seulement du diocèse
de chicoutimi où des fabriques d'église
même accepté c'était non stop
les accouchements les caresses renée
millette a conservé les notes de toutes
ces rencontres des quarts vie en prison
elle a été la dernière avocats du
pédophile bourrine impossible que le
diocèse de chicoutimi n'ait pas été au
courant
donc ça ça pouvait pas ne pas savoir au
niveau de l'ailé giroud des élèves
pourquoi ça ça c'est un passé renée
millette et tout en plus convaincus que
juste avant de mourir en prison à
signé une déclaration assermentée dans
laquelle il affirme avoir parlé de ces
crimes à l'évêque de l'époque
monseigneur marieuse paris qui lui
aurait simplement dit de prier davantage
et de faire attention aux enfants
harvey a été changée paroisse une
douzaine de fois en 20 ans alors quand
rémy est entend dire qu'aller vers
chicoutimi on n'était au courant de rien
ah mais non mais c'est pas possible
avec tout ce qui me racontait là
monsieur hervé toutes les fois que
l'évêque lui parle ou son représentant
change de paroisses la police tout le
dossier j'écoutais ça pas de sens
puis on fait juste le changer de place
on lui dit pris puisqu'au prudent sans
conséquence
sans conséquence et s'était ainsi de
suite et au travers de ça il ya quatre
voix des policiers qui l'ont convoquée
ou qui sont venus voir
l'évêque de chicoutimi qui a succédé à
monségur paris c'est monseigneur jean
guy couture aujourd'hui à la retraite
pendant plusieurs années il a été
lévesque responsable de la bea revêt
mais alors que savait monseigneur
couture
[Musique]
monseigneur couture a accepté de nous
rencontrer sans caméra là où il habite
dans une maison de retraite
le diocèse de chicoutimi a eu vent de
notre rencontre et a voulu nous empêcher
de lui parler et l'assemblée des évêques
du québec s'en est aussi mêlée
d'ailleurs nous avons écrit à
l'assemblée des évêques du québec pour
parler de la responsabilité des évêques
dans toute cette crise on nous a répondu
que l'instance qui a seule l'autorité
sur les diocèses et les évêques et bien
c'est le pas uniquement le pape à rome
un joueur incontournable sur ces
questions c'est le préfet de la
congrégation pour les évêques le
cardinal marc ouellet du fois plutôt
qu'une
nous lui avons demandé une entrevue mais
il a refusé de nous rencontrer
[Musique]
même si harvey a sévi dans le diocèse
pendant que monseigneur couture en était
l'évêque et que quatre policiers sont
intervenus auprès de l'agresseur même si
aujourd'hui une centaine de victimes
prises mais pour suivre le diocèse de
chicoutimi
monseigneur couture nous dit qu'ils
n'étaient au courant de rien quand j'en
ai entendu parler
j'étais horrifiée et laissez moi vous
dire que ça en prend beaucoup pour
modifier chicoutimi est un bon exemple
pourquoi un procès pourquoi ça continue
pourquoi l'évêque ne disent ils pas nous
reconnaissons avoir fait ça nous sommes
coupables nous sommes désolés mais les
avocats continuent de se battre alors
honduras sont nos avocats qui nous
disent quoi faire
c'est ça le truc mais non dans le
royaume uni au québec bien des victimes
réclament la tenue d'une commission
d'enquêté pour faire la lumière sur les
crimes de pédophilie mais reste à
convaincre la ministre de la justice du
québec à ce stade si l'outil
la commission d'enquêté peut-être pas la
venue la propre la plus appropriée dans
ce dossier tu as beau ça c'est tout une
connerie êtes vous sérieux une en tête
au québec ce serait comme labourer un
champ de mines
ça ressemblerait à ça une véritable
enquête au québec nous apprendrait
vraiment beaucoup de choses m'ont
quelque chose à terre-neuve ça fait
maintenant trente ans comme si on avait
cherché à effacer les preuves de
l'horreur l'orphelinat a été démoli tout
ça c'était m'en cacher donc aujourd'hui
on y trouve une piscine
c'est ce mémorial après sa mort ils ont
tout ce qu'il reste de l'orphelinat des
garçons devant cachot et si ce petit
bout de terrain en mémoire dont le ciqi
pas le mot gravé sur les vieilles
pierres
à l'ombre des noms de ceux qui se sont
enlevé la vie ou ceux qui comme ben
helli luttent chaque jour à la recherche
d'une vie ordinaire bellissen la colère
qui gronde en lui il n'en revient pas
tout près à quelques dizaines de mètres
d'ici c'est l'un qui est revenu habiter
un des pires agresseurs de manque à
chaud d'un kenny et comme pour tourner
le fer dans la plaie c'est juste de
l'autre côté de la rue en face d'une
garderie
[Musique]
pendant qu'à rome ont écrit de nouveaux
discours pour dire combien les disait
désolé
ils sont des milliers des dizaines de
milliers à tenter de reconstruire leur
vie parfois en passant par les tribunaux
pour que ceux qui devaient les protéger
des évêques et même des cardinaux
reconnaisse enfin qu'ils ont plutôt
ouvert les portes de l'enfer aux enfants
de l'église
[Musique]